und dadurch unsere erfolg erzielt und
die boarder sie leuchtet auf und wird
wie ein stückchen größer genau jetzt
geht das ganze nämlich nach außen und
wir haben mehr platz und das ist unser
ziel dass wir das immer größer werden
wir den dahinten kisten wie hey ho
minecraft freunde willkommen zu einem
neuen größeren projekt zusammen mit
contractor wir spielen heute oder auch
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
gemeinsam indikator dass der doch die
karte skeptisch minecraft hallo erstmal
auch an meine zuschauer die folge kommt
bei uns beiden die zweite würde ich
sagen kommt dabei komme die dritte
richtlinien bei mir immer wieder bekomme
und alle ungarn folgen bei mir und wir
wollen es immer abwechseln hochladen ich
denke wir kriegen das auch hin wenn sie
anderswo schaffen und ich erklär soll
ich mal ganz gut erklärt mal die sache
skeptisch minecraft ist sehr sehr cool
ich habe einfach mal aufhören ein
bisschen nachgeschaut was gibt's denn so
viel karten die wie skype blog sind weil
ich mal wieder bock auf sky lok hatte
und dann habe ich auch dieses habe ich
die skeptischen minecraft hier gefunden
wird da seht schon tausendmal geiler typ
ich lächelte geiste seit eben gerade als
sich dann schon so ein paar sachen
sinngrund uns also es wird cool
das wird richtig cool vor allem jemanden
schritt nach draußen dann siehst du dass
dein bildschirm so ein bisschen rot wird
das heißt hier kannst du nichts machen
du kannst nichts abbauen schlag
versuchen gras kaputt nicht rot dann bis
zum brot am rand nicht mehr eigentlich
nicht obwohl es doch noch kann sein
versuch mal gras kaputt zu machen oder
so wenn und außerhalb stehst kannst du
nicht mehr geht nicht nur das halt das
in der ich mir in diesen drei bereichen
weg hat stehen und eigentlich war das
sogar noch ein kleiner und man muss ich
schief - erzielen wenn wir immer in die
einstellungen gehen und auf erfolge
klicken
sehen wir inventur den haben wir schon
gemacht weil bombe hat außerdem gedrückt
aber dass er nicht schlimm da wir warten
warten vorher nur ein blog platz jetzt
haben wir schon 3 mal 3 fällt und mit
jeder statistik wird diese jedem erfolg
den wir schaffen also der nächste
dreimal auf holz geklopft also schlage
einen baum bis ein stück holz heraus
fällt macht das mal genauer mache ich
mal so ich habe zwar schon mehrmals als
öfter als dreimal gemacht aber das holz
und gar nicht unsere erfolg erzielt und
die boarder sie leuchtet auf und wird
wieder ein stückchen größer genau jetzt
geht das ganze nämlich nach außen und
wir haben mehr platz und das ist unser
ziel dass wir das immer größer werden
wir den dahinten kisten und jetzt ist
zum beispiel was genau mit jedem erfolg
einfach wird das immer und immer größere
wir werden immer cooleren map abschnitte
hier kennenlernen und gerade so dieses
erfolgs ging das mal wirklich diese
erfolge von minecraft hiermit benutze
ich extrem cool wenn ich jetzt mal
weiterschauen der stelle eine werkbank
ich habe schon zwei eichenholz deswegen
mache ich mir mal eben hier kurzem
werkbank doch macht das mal bewerten und
oder hannover die fans mit dir also ich
würde sagen wir lassen die erstmal leben
oder ich stelle die werkbank war dahin
seine werte nicht raus diese auch
gefangen das ist aber richtig cool ich
hätte erst gedacht dass das so
abgesperrt ist oder so was
aber das ist echt cool das ist wirklich
mit diesem alles mit command blogs also
wenn ich selber spielen wollte das ist
irgendwie snapshot 14 425 b und das
coole ist auch wenn man nach oben guckst
du siehst dann auch insel nahm
ganz oben nur da oh ja ich hab mir das
ja schon mal angeguckt und trailer und
so da oben sind noch inseln wo du in den
nenner gehen kannst alles mögliche was
auch noch schief mit es gibt und alles
genau für den baum weiter ab ich schaue
schon mal weiter was 8,3 auf den erfolg
erzielt ja wie wird die jetzt auch noch
größer an den nil wahrscheinlich
erfolgreich wirtschaft jetzt können sie
mich entscheiden jetzt haben nämlich
drei verschiedene sachen bei den
erfolgen schauen wir bei erfolgen eher
mit entweder anbau eine felljacke bauer
ein schwert oder bau eine spitzhacke ja
immer sagen dass das du die spitzhacke
macht und ich mache die feld hacke und
das schwert alles klar machen wir das so
groß dass schon die werkbank aufgestellt
dass man holzer verdammt ich hab ja ich
hab dir mein holz zugeworfen kann ich
das kurz wir haben da wunderbare war
damals erst mal im wasser so dass das
ist super super aber ich kann jetzt live
mitverfolgen wie die insel ihrer nähe
das ist ja keine insel wir unser gesicht
einfach sagt ist unser captain bligh ich
hoffe wir kriegen
setzlinge daraus oder ich hab sogar
schon einen nicht noch blöde soso und
genau und ich hab die spitzhacke gemacht
und ich mag alle welt wir müssen
eigentlich uns etwas einfallen lassen
wenn das ganze ding größer wird er
brauchen wir gesund tanz der rumba etwas
anderes können wir denn da machen cool
ist weil es sich ja schon was besonderes
ist
am anfang ist relativ schnell gleich
haben schon die erste kiste da und hier
in james bond
ich bin zwar wir lassen das erste mal
leben bis wir das fleisch irgendwie
brauchen also soll ich mir hier schon
ein setzling hinsetzen einfach jedoch
manchmal machen der brauchte seine zeit
um zu wachsen
ich schaue schon mal weiter folgen
wienerberger hat mal zum brot machen ja
brot ist noch schwierig weil wir noch
kein wasser haben wir können schon mal
das gras ein bisschen kaputt schlagen
ich hab schon super der zwischenhandel
hier liegt neuer ok ja selbst den
einfach da ein jahr gelaufen
gegen die mit ich ich hab auch denkt ob
dieser form jetzt hier wächst also ob er
über diese grenze hinaus wächst obwohl
müsste er eigentlich der andere war auch
am anfang über der grenze hinaus richtig
und wir werden ja auch noch weiter
kommen konnte kommen wir da ran an die
truhe kommen wir auch nicht hier ist
wirklich alles einfach eingegrenzt ja
wir können darauf klicken und alles also
das wird richtig richtig cool fallen wir
sind wirklich auf diesem kleinen raum
sowie bei sky bleibt da konntest du die
insel halt selber er weiter wenn du
drauf wenn du bock drauf hat ist aber
hier geht halt nicht pate kann man nicht
mit samen in die paare die damit nicht
das geht auch mit weinwissen glaube ich
oder war es nicht so mit ihnen welchen
körnern oder aber die weil die gucken
mich zu an weizen gehandhabt hast du
eigentlich was dort als einfach verdammt
haben uns aus bekommen das hatten wir
die eventuellen partnern egal ob
arbeiter bei den erfolgen in hast du ich
habe auch ein schwert mission mal
gemacht schubser sammeln etwas leder der
dann mit töten oder macht zwar habe ich
gemacht als neuer kalender halten
nein dann kein leder was machen wir da
wir müssen wahrscheinlich dann noch mal
abwarten anna erfolg machen und da gibt
es doch bestimmt
es gibt natürlich noch andere
verständlich man sich der unfall nicht
einen monster gibt es
diese ackern schaufel hast du dir schon
mal gemacht also diese wie heißt die
mama hast du eine spitzhacke gemacht
aber ich gemacht ja hier hoher guckt er
die schöne spitze kann ist sie schön ist
die schön so dass wir da nur dein
erfolgen angezeigt ich dachte bei mir
wird nicht angezeigt dass sie eine
spitzhacke hab weil man einfach mal so
ein bisschen uns nach unten graben oder
so mal schauen wenn wir machen
wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal ein erfolg
das blöd dass weder kein leder
rausbekommen
aber egal das ist eigentlich gar nicht
so wichtig man vielleicht erhalten wir
aus der truhe jetzt noch lang wien
sportec führende cooler so weiß ich
nicht wir können es jetzt mich am rand
untergraben dann seht ihr auch dass die
grenze nicht nur in diesem gebiet
sondern auch nach unten und oben hin
die ganze zeit weitergeht genauen kannst
du mir hast du noch reichen holzbretter
ich hab gar kein holz mehr
also da muss jetzt mal wir warten hast
du noch irgendwie was oder ich habe
einen schock ich habe auch noch weichen
holz weiter in aurich zu 30 mal seine
schaufel gibt es dafür ein archiv mit
ich weiß es nicht weil gibt es nicht
mist ich hätte mich sonst dieser hackl
gemacht diese welt ein grad ab genau die
haben schon die habe ich schon gemacht
ach so da ist das ja alles schon größer
geworden gerade echt extrem eben lange
mit der schaufel also ohne schaufel
na ja und auch gar kein stein engen wie
kann es sein dass sie kein stein kommt
oder dauert das nur eine weile ich glaub
es dauert eine weile auf den stein ich
hab schon steil
ich hab eine spitzhacke warte mal ja
dann baut man hier stein ab ach so du
hast du auch schon
obwohl ich schon mal ganz gut mit den
erfolgen dann kommt dann anrufen anrufen
du kannst jetzt machen dass das nächste
tief mit und du hast ja die spitzhacke
gemacht deswegen musst du jetzt die ganz
wichtig wenn es machen mit der
spitzhacke und wie machnig und
schwertern oder du machst dann auch noch
mal ein schwert und blabla aber wir
können die items auf jeden fall teilen
und so was alles ich bin ja mal gespannt
wie weit wir da kommen werden
ich bin auch gespannt also es sind ein
paar
gameplay tipps auf der website die auch
unten in der beschreibung steht fest ist
wirklich selber spielen aber ich denke
das macht auch wenn wir das alleine
spielt macht es auch spaß natürlich mit
ihrem freund da wie kann man echt heftig
aber ich denke warum warum warum warum
warum warum warum warum warum leute
schreibt man spürt die idee hin wir sind
dann zeigen wir die kurve was alle
bekannten und ananas ist ein humba an
du bist immer um diese weise blog den er
das herum machen zeigen wie und hier
sind um brach das ist in graz prof
was soll dieser quatsch blog eigentlich
zeigen ins ponton wahrscheinlich oder da
sein wir doch mal startet ja stimmt wie
kommen wir auch nicht ran verdammen ich
möchte eigentlich herankommen an die
truhe
das interessiert mich einfach extrem was
da geht dann kommt ich stimme dir rufen
wir nehmen dann hast du musst jetzt eine
stein spitzhacke machen
okay du hast den rufen egal die stein
spitzhacke ja ich habe aber kein holz ja
ich habe heute das gleiche geben hier
nix was man macht gerade fühle der hohen
ball tanz ach guck mal komme drückt ab
da kannst du sehen wie viel ich finde
wir beide haben das ist am wettstreit
echt jetzt ich weiß nicht ob wir das als
mitstreitern ansehen soll jetzt haben
wir alles so gesehen war gucken am ende
so casper van assche spitzhacke doch
nicht ich wollte mich noch mal machen
für den tanz und ich hab sie so und
jetzt um bonbon warum das schwein
wir lassen das schwein oder auch noch
mal leben nein noch eine tiefland bis
zur ruhe
okay was machen wir jetzt nächstes dass
man nach schon nicht oder baum ist groß
gewachsen warten können
ich mache jetzt einfach auch noch eine
spitzhacke dann kann ich die nächste
nicht mit ja auch noch machen ich
brauche ihn nachher noch ein steinschlag
und alles gedruckt du sammelst meinhold
laden ein
ich gehe jetzt hier unter anderem das
wäre ich gehe also wenn es nacht wird
dann gehe ich immer meine hülle hier
fackeln können uns auch gleich schon
machen dann höre stimmt werden wir wenn
wir holz mit holz verbrennen stimmt
stimmt stimmt ich glaube dass jetzt sehr
sehr cool
wir können ja auch sagen falls wir in
sotschi fans ein bisschen länger sind
dass ihr uns eventuell auch themen
schreibt über die wir reden soll oder
dass ihr uns vielleicht auch tipps gibt
oder so zu diesem projekt ihr seid dann
natürlich mit ein
würde ich das machen ja ein ob das halt
eingelegt echte zu ein schönes bekommt
man dafür auch erinnerungen geschafft so
dass ich bestimmte ende
oder ich weiß nicht wie lange ich meine
skelett was du das auch ob ich je nach
nähe von der höhle war ja ich glaube ich
stoße gleich auf möbel oder das buch
denn leute es ist wahrscheinlich bei
euch gerade extrem dunkel ich brauch
fackeln wir müssen erstmal fackeln
machen
ja ich bin schon dabei weil ich möchte
keine dunkle aufnahmen hochland wo man
einfach nur schwarzen bildschirm sieht
so warte weg können aber auch meiner
frau
man braucht ja vielleicht so und dann
kriegen wir gleich schon die ersten
klasse noch stäbe oder wir machen uns
erstmal so wenig fackeln wie möglich
wird sagen dadurch haben wir jetzt eine
kohle das sind 4 fackeln okay dann
stelle ich eine einfach hierhin warte
ich mach das mal ganz kurz zu
ich stelle mir eigentlich auf den spot
punkt und den rest gebe ich dir für
deine hülle
danke schön wenn ich das hier und jetzt
64 fackel machen mit dem ganzen holz
sondern eine ganz andere ja ich war so
ich geh jetzt mir immer auch mal ganz
kurz steiner holen damit ich mir meine
stein spitzhacke machen kann
37 für dich warte mal hier gefühle
brauchst du drei stücke naja ich habe
jetzt schon drei abgeholt oh ja gut für
gut nämlich meine hilfe gewartet jetzt
manchmal eine stein spitzhacke und dann
hab ich demnächst das nächste tief mit
und ich stoße gleich auf die erste öl
und ich hab kohle gefunden
cool super und eisen auch gut reisen ist
so gar nicht das eisen musste gleich
braten stimmt ja und dann haben wir dann
können die kiste macht das schnell
wieder an die kiste oder oder komm wir
machen das in der nächsten folge gleich
genau was in der kiste ist das wird dann
nur bei ghom sollen
die dritte folge seiner familie die
vitte ist bekomme und so weiter denn wir
wollen das ganze geteilt hochladen mal
wieder wie bei den apple jump maps das
heißt die nächste gar die nächste folge
wo wir die trawler erforschen die landen
kommt bei mir auf dem kanal
denn am tag danach wieder die folge bei
con crafter und immer dem rhythmus
weiter spricht immer abwechselnd ist
eigentlich zu verstehen von crafter ist
auch ganz oben in der beschreibung
verlinkt
ja dann komme auch schreib doch mal eure
meinung in die kommentare zu der karte
genau diesen findet die karte findet ihr
auch ihr könnt euch den trailer angucken
und alles mögliche natürlich sagen es
euch gefallen hat zeigt uns mit einer
bewertung und ich hoffe wir haben viel
spaß bei dem projekt und bisher ist es
richtig richtig geil
genau kann gerne so produktiv weiter
gehen also leute haut rein und schön mit